I'm Gregg Alda I would need a stargazer
we are knit my tip showing tonight today
you have gone the views on this video
family probably hence Gregory you twos
mean content yes they are being content
less shall you get positive results you
give out negative feedback to presenting
the secret Tommy to get the opposite you
must do the opposite I think I might've
taken at the wrong way I think you like
said listen guys don't listen it's the
month of May we launched the patreon in
April holy crap it's been amazing the
community over there is growing just
want to say thank you to everyone but I
won't spend too much time on it because
I know I spent a lot of time on a laelia
video it comes at night trailer number
uno hahaha
what I didn't say anything weird how has
the title taking out an E and replacing
John with a you makes it a very
different movie listen um I saw the
teaser trailer for this it was really
spooky doesn't tell you anything about
the film I loved the way it was shot and
Nita hasn't sent a teaser trailer she's
gonna watch this
we welcome only only guacamole rated our
violin
[Music]
[Music]
this one is offering and I want honest
answers do you have any idea what's
going on out there
[Music]
he's got some chills Nita I'm going to
try to help you in your trainer and one
Becky gave the winners clear
grunts you're a few things when they go
out during the day we like to stick the
group suggester City
very report houses this close and lock
red door come on head keys the only set
will support thing with the thing okay
let's go inside
we never go out at night this minecraft
the movie over that red door you and me
the two of you gonna put the mask on
nobody's picking I can't trust anyone
good family
[Music]
okay
[Music]
what is it it just there's two movies
coming out this year they have it in the
title one of them just being the word it
also you find out what is it it's it
it's it yeah look an accountant reminds
you of like cabin fever I don't know
that song by the way I kinda remind you
cabin fever now again kind of rises you
have a fever no more man pit
what is it Mel I'm sorry it kinda
reminds you of like cabin fever did you
see the witch I did yeah a little bit of
that really okay Oh kind of like the
tone yeah I mean it's modern day but
Fisher but like it looks like a lot of
slow-moving shots a lot of eerie on
building dimension into the Sun of
cinnamon in your mana demography is like
I know what I'm gonna say that I watch
movies if you review it
I've seen the lightening movies I am an
avid watcher um and I've been to the
talkies and my leg is nothing like that
kind of way in its shine I mean it's
interesting how a lot of this centers
around the whole theme of the Red Door
yeah a red looked a lot of the ways
lamps at the top of the land with red
flag and word regrets at least today I'm
tired
it's how I look at early o'clock in the
morning yeah you have yeah after
drinking a lot more yeah hey i order she
um forgive me for not smarting it's okay
smarting it out and joel edgerton he
kinda reminds me i was going to go for
this joel edgerton the dad he does kinda
remind me he's like Vin Diesel from Fast
and the Furious meet Andrew Lincoln from
Walking Dead Rick yeah I did yeah I got
like both live Sherman is all about
family could only try
family but he also he doesn't have the
southern accent but it kind of the way
you read everything but what about
particular yeah yeah I felt that for the
the interracial couple here why when she
went to kiss him and on the blood he's
Lexi if there's oh really house people
oh well [ __ ] up all kinds Anita
broken Anita yes Gregory remember can
you spit on me like that in the bedroom
and I was like you're bleeding
everywhere and you're like I would like
but it comes from you what cuz every
time of the month even happen through
the mouth okay because I first went down
on me yeah gotcha
geez what is wrong with CIA knows a
channel people you know create a sexual
attention you don't say you're together
because the whole point of it is you
want Jim and Pam to get together the
whole time the whole time like why the
hell aren't they getting together
ratings go down
what's the yeah that's what happened
that's what happens right now time for
each other didn't they get me what I
wanted it even if you haven't started
the office yet don't Billy just told you
how it all unfolded a little what about
the movie it's super intrigued because
in a beautiful it was like super
beautiful like I loved it I loved it the
shot where you can see all the trees and
like putting this above it oh yeah yeah
they're very isolated from yeah from
whatever type of weird because it was
showing like they they're turning into
something like I don't know what we know
India is it an actual monster to the
nominee hobby is it just a type of fire
attack virus thing that's happening
teach it that devil what would be if you
this sick ooh just don't roll that way
oh no no can you be packing a gun to
take on the demon the cross-shaped on
somebody's 18 Russia keep it
every lots of subs right there sorry I
mean I like these contain stories that
take place in a bigger world like
there's something else happening in the
world do you really think that that's
what the idea that was is that there's
something else happening yeah that's why
they're tactical in that area I think
that's why they're hiding out in the
cabin okay because if they stay away
from whatever just reading in like
population they can be safe hey that's
why they don't want strangers coming in
and all that [ __ ] they don't know what's
going on I love that that contained type
of vibe of there's something bigger
happening but we're focusing on this one
hideout yeah there's one little room and
see what happens we had great kind of
like how the mist is how there's like a
big thing happening but it takes place
in this this supermarket the whole time
where people are trapped in there you're
watching the evolution of that yeah
and that's kind of the same vibe that I
have here except in a much more like
underlying Kirito it looks like you did
get a one glyphs or look like they're
like they turn into some kind of some
kind of monster like Metallica
no song no song you don't have face no
more you're getting me my son doing it
name this song you want a piece of me I
can see how you laugh I have a feeling
they're all going to die I don't I don't
know what gives you that impression I
thought that they were all going to
survive it yeah maybe a blind guy was
gonna come out on top to be remembered
American this is YouTube yes I'm sorry
black you might not be African he could
have been Ethiopian because then he
could've in Jamaican it could have been
Jamaican gonna been a Jamaican ameno who
is the racist in there yeah take that
piece take that know what help us if we
just read the actual plot description I
would probably help us yes
secure within a desolate home as an
unnatural threat terrorizes the world
a man has established a tenuous domestic
order with his wife and son but this
will soon
he puts a test when a desperate young
family arrives Zeke you were happy
that's cool so you're focusing on the
family and you're focusing on the and
the other family and strangers yeah and
I imagine it'll be a clash of how they
should go about surviving this scuse me
and let's get that up and we're gonna
kind of pick a little calm but yeah but
maybe want to be religious really hashas
when I give not go to churches of it
came on men I'm going straight to the
flames of hell look at things is some
type of virus things started happening
zombies or whatever I would immediately
be that guy in the group going it's the
apocalypse that's with Revelations
talked about Michael being that yeah how
would you snap back into believing all
those things and I would be like aliens
are here so it's interesting because
we've got two families to choose from
yeah like whose side we're going to be
honor who do we think is going to be the
bad guy monster what is it a monster boy
yeah I mean are they looking to turn
ever against and Serena from eight dates
or had we get a sacred okay who's got
the virus to which family is brought it
in there so that's going to be the
people that were like again like oh man
we brought it into this um you know
situation or these innocent people came
into a situation where the virus was
there it looks like a lot of this
suspense will play on territory envelope
definitely
and how do well probably like I bet
it'll be a seam of don't over the door I
have to open the door to order girl I'm
us but it's gonna be deaf because my dad
was dependent all righty then yes Jim
Carrey
subscribe to the regex
real regex it's woman not is right here
than you are any women I need a
stargazer boobs and penis and everything
both both oh oh woman because she
believes yeah hey Lisa what time her car
got broken into
something slightly alien alien and they
know they know I would like this is God
telling God oh you you cheat okay
later later that's why we broke up
that's a bit come another yeah yeah you
know if you conflict with your views of
the world and who created you yeah you
know I believe aliens did it you believe
God did it you know alien very you know
there's way more proof that God exists
oh really
ah hey yeah do that thing go check out
her channel I'm gonna get out you cannot
those important thing is that you
subscribe to the real reach end card
only comes at the last 30 seconds o
outro has been over a minute you know
this jump cut thing that they do
I'm not going to come take all this
materials gold while editing it with me
20 minute long available I cut it it's
funny